decade megyn kelly was a fixture here at
Fox in early 2017 she moved to NBC where
among many other things she anchored the
third hour of The Today Show turned out
to be a very turbulent year for NBC NBC
executives were caught covering up for
accused sex criminal Harvey Weinstein
meanwhile the network's most famous
anchor Matt Lauer fled the building
after he was implicated in a laundry
list of misdeeds an awful lot of drama
for one Network megyn kelly was right
there to see all of it she left her show
last October she's not done a single
televised interview since we're happy to
have her on our set tonight I think
Ellie joins us now Meghan good to see
you hi good to be with you
so this Ronan Farrow book adds details
to what we essentially knew which is
that NBC executives and ELAC
particularly know Oppenheim I think that
of NBC News covered up for Harvey
Weinstein so here's what Ronan Pharaoh's
book says and I want your reaction to
this quote Farrell brings a recording
made by the NYPD to NBC and in it
Harvey Weinstein admits that he abused
an Italian model on tape no oftentime
head of the news division responds this
way quote my view is that the tape and
Harvey Weinstein grabbing the lady's
breasts a couple of years ago that's not
national news does that surprise you
having worked there you know nothing
surprises me anymore Tucker in this
industry I as I haven't watched the
Ronan story unfold as his book has come
out Ronan Farrow catch and kill the
number one thing I've wanted to know is
what do they know and when did they know
it right because I've been reporting on
this story even while I was at NBC I
talked to Ronan I talked to his producer
rich McHugh I talked to Rose McGowan I
talked to many Harvey Weinstein victims
and accusers and was getting to the
bottom of what NBC knew while I was
there and then just independently and
the question is what did they know about
Matt Lauer prior to the time the woman
came forward who was ultimately his
downfall she came forward her name is
Brooke Neville's made an allegation
against Matt Lauer and the company's
whole defense to Ronan's book
essentially has been that's the first we
ever knew about Matt Lauer there was no
deal between us
and Harvey Weinstein - cover up for
Harvey Weinstein so that he wouldn't
report on Matt Lauer because we didn't
even know that Matt Lauer was doing this
we had no notice of it whatsoever is
that is that a plausible claim if they
had no settlements of any kind and no
complaints about Matt Lauer prior to
Brooke novels coming forward sure it
might be but is that true
here's the wit what they're saying no
settlements of any kind no settlement
well that that's a legal sleight of hand
you can get paid out as a sexual
harassment victim in something other
than a settlement you can get what's
called enhanced severance that's the
situation where the receptionist is
suddenly getting a seven-figure goodbye
do you have like an amazing typist just
so well right and it's just severance
it's not a settlement it's just like hey
and by the way if you could just be
really quiet about NBC forevermore we'd
really appreciate it that's what we need
to know they haven't gotten specific
about what monies were paid out to whom
show us the money the number one thing
that needs to happen now is they need to
release any and all Matt Lauer accusers
from their confidentiality agreements
NBC says it has nothing to hide great
let's not hide anything
show us all of the agreements that
enhance severance agreements that were
reached or at least the numbers so we
can see which ones pop out which ones
are super high and are they all women
and do they all have a connection with
Matt Lauer and number two release the
women from their confidentiality
obligations so this probably would be
known right now
if the network had conducted an
independent investigation last September
early September you on your show on the
air on NBC called for an independent
investigation into these allegations I
think we have the tape of you doing this
but there is a question about whether
there should be an outside investigator
to take a hard look at this you know
between the investigation NBC did
internally on Matt Lauer so now this you
know there's there's the question of the
faith and confidence of the public in
the in the reporting and of NBC on
matters involving itself and it's to me
as a lawyer it's just always better if
you if you just send it outside and then
people can have more faith in it and if
there's nothing to hide do you you have
no worries about it you know you have
nothing to worry about
so people's jaws hung open
you said that there have been a couple
of published accounts that say you were
fired from NBC a little more than a
month later for saying that with that in
mind without even having you comment on
it I want to get your response to
something that an anchor at MSNBC did
two nights ago Chris Hayes addressed the
credibility of the president of NBC News
directly on a show he said this
Oppenheim and others have also
maintained since pharaoh's departure two
years ago the Weinstein story was never
broadcast because it lacked sufficient
on the record sourcing even after NBC
supported Pharaoh's assignment for seven
months one thing though is indisputable
Ronan Farrow walked out of MBC news
after working on the Weinstein story and
within two months published an
incredible article The New Yorker the
path of least resistance is always there
beckoning seductively with an entirely
plausible cover story you've got bigger
fish to fry this is the hell to die on
the story isn't ready but of course it's
the very ease of that path that makes it
the enemy the kind of work that we as
journalists are supposed to do he's
saying essentially what you said which
is he doesn't trust the management at
NBC News given your experience do you
think he's in jeopardy of being fired no
comment on that but I will say the
question is open as to whether they put
dollars ahead of decency about whether
they were more interested in protecting
their star anchor than they weren't
protecting the women of the company
there needs to be an outside
investigation into this company they
investigated themselves that doesn't
work
Fox News had an outside investigator CBS
News had an outside investigator NPR the
NFL this is how it's done you get
somebody on the outside who can be
trusted what happened here is you've got
Noah Oppenheim who now they're pulling
his college writings where he said women
love to be preyed on apparently he
thinks women love to be preyed upon okay
now what Noah has said I deeply regret
that and I'm sorry for what I wrote in
college and people do write dumb ass
things in college and say dumb things to
trust me
but that's the person who was who's
investigating himself and ELAC Noah's
I'm sorry the reporting that Ronan has
put out is that there is an accuser are
a woman named Jane Wallace who said she
was bullied at
her job when working for Andy years ago
she had a consensual affair with him but
then she says he was retaliated against
and she says he relentlessly preyed on
female and female underlings if these
are the people overseeing the
investigation into NBC right they had
Kim Harris the general counsel do the
investigation how are people supposed to
trust it that's why you've got to get
somebody on the other side but it's also
there's a striking irony so even as the
management of NBC clearly ignored sexual
misconduct and abuse within their own
building they they seemed to pump up and
abet wild and unsubstantiated
allegations of sexual misconduct against
people whose politics they don't like so
for example I watched you on a panel at
NBC when you work there last year on kab
note was the last story I think you
covered before you left do Savannah
Guthrie and Lester Holt and Chuck Todd
were all on this panel you were the only
person on the panel who held out the
possibility that maybe Brett Kavanaugh
was not a rapist did you feel like the
only person who was capable of being
objective on that question well I mean
there's no question that the the
reporting that was done at NBC on
somebody like let's take Julie sweat
Nick Wright was the completely
discredited alleged third accuser
against Kavanaugh this is the woman
whose story had I mean tons of holes and
edges you know then there was a date
rape and everybody saw it and then
nobody saw it and she basically imploded
on the air Suzanne avenatti client
remembers vividly they went to air with
that story with far less trepidation
than they showed in going to air on the
Harvey Weinstein's story for which they
had tapes they had tapes they had
witnesses they had women on the record
Rose McGowan was just one of them and
there is a question of why right was it
political as you suggest here was it
something else was it to protect
somebody internally someone who wasn't
the women of the company right because
here what Ron is suggesting is that they
covered up for one sexual predator
Harvey Weinstein in order to protect
another Matt Lauer they deny all of this
and NBC has put out several statements
saying that Ronan is a conspiracy
theorist and this is all nonsense and
he's got an axe to grind but if that's
true and there's nothing to hide then
get an outside investigator yeah if
there's nothing to hide
megyn kelly hasn't been on TV for years
she's got a lot to say we're happy to
have her in our studio tonight thanks to
Ronan Farrow in the last week we've
learned a lot about the lengths to which
some NBC executives went in order to
cover up sexual abuse the details are so
stunning even some on the left
presumably NBC viewers themselves have
expressed outrage earlier today the
feminist group ultraviolet issued this
statement quote the DNC needs to make it
clear they support survivors of sexual
abuse and cancel the upcoming 2020
Democratic presidential primary debate
on MSNBC until Comcast and NBC News take
clear steps to clean up the toxic
culture that exists across their
networks megyn kelly do you think
there's any chance the DNC will act on
that I do think there's a chance I do I
mean I think if this were Fox News and
Fox News were hosting a democratic
debate in conjunction with the
Washington Post yes they'd be putting on
the full-court press to make sure Fox
was out or Fox made some sort of a
promise to clean up its act so I do I
take that seriously because once you
know people are not screwing around
anymore when it comes to the treatment
of women right and what used to be
tolerated will not be tolerated anymore
it's not that we have a perfect culture
like that when we recognize there's a
problem it's that companies are given
the opportunity to sort of come clean
investigate what the problems are and
come up with real solutions NBC says
it's done that they say you can trust
Kim Harris the internal GC and Ronan's
given us about 400 reasons to doubt that
right so it's it's really up to the
public are they going to put the
pressure on them to do something to get
an outside investigator or aren't they
so one of the most amazing
I think details in the book maybe not so
surprising is that Hillary Clinton
applied pressure to Pharaoh he says not
to pursue the Harvey Weinstein story and
so I wonder and of course I don't know
the truth that's his claim why is no one
asked Hillary Clinton about this I
wonder it may be eventually they will I
mean there are a lot of fish to fry
there yeah and I think Hillary's
spokesperson has come out and said it
was nothing and it's been misrepresented
right so they're they're kind of denying
that but look more needs to happen in
order for us to get to the bottom of
this you've got NBC says there was no
way for them to know any of this right
because the they didn't know anything
until Brooke nevels came in
and only at that point did a couple more
women come forward and say you know me
too
the truth is that we've seen already
there was a diese known she came on my
show I had her on my shelf while I was
at NBC she had a consensual affair with
Lauer she was 24 years old he plucked
her out of being a PA and started an
affair with her
then there was Brook Neville's 30 years
old assistant to Meredith Vieira who
same thing and you know all the multiple
ways of you know and she says she was
raped by him he's denied that and said
it was a consensual affair there was
Melissa lonner who said he exposed
himself to her one night after an NBC
party and that she ultimately went and
left the company there was a woman who
claims she had sex with him in his
office and she fainted it was a matter
remember there's an Curry says we know
an open secret so the question is did
they if they didn't know why didn't they
know well they're lying why didn't they
they're lying but it doesn't diminish
the self righteousness with which they
approach other people's sins I noticed
so I want to ask you since you worked
here at Fox News you worked at NBC you
got some perspective I want to ask you
about the state of journalism today and
and I want to start with a clip from
last night's debate this is Anderson
Cooper at CNN asking a question of the
former Vice President Joe Biden watch
this the impeachment inquiry is centered
on president Trump's attempts to get
political dirt from Ukraine on Vice
President Biden and his son hunter mr.
vice president president Trump has
falsely accused your son of doing
something wrong while serving on a
company board in Ukraine I want to point
out there's no evidence of wrongdoing by
either one of you so what kind of
journalist begins a question to a
politician by reassuring him that
attacks by his opponents are false and
he's actually innocent is that is that a
question so that could the answer was
kind of baked into the question in there
I know it's great he did nothing wrong
but did you do anything wrong exactly
listen that wasn't Anderson's best
moment I like Anderson that wasn't his
best moment I think his question
would've been fine if he said that you
didn't do anything illegal
no one's alleged you did anything
illegal because really what the guy did
was he sat on a board a hunter Biden has
no expertise in Ukraine he has no
expertise in natural gas he takes his
job sitting on the board
Ukrainian company for 50,000 bucks a
month while his dad is the vice
president and the reason he got that job
is presumably his last name is Biden so
they're paying for access they're paying
for you know the Association is that is
that corrupt you could make a very
strong argument that it is so is it
wrong well that's up to the voters to
decide so you know it may be he could
have reworded that maybe you'd like that
one but but it's it it's and I agree
with you by the way I know Anderson
Cooper fairly well I don't think he's
the worst offender but this is part of a
larger tapestry here and it adds up to -
basically partisan interference in an
election me you have journalists who
feel that their first obligation is to
help a candidate or hurt another oh yeah
that's not journalists 100% and this
goes back to right before Trump was
elected Jorge Ramos of Univision came on
my show and and we had a very heartfelt
discussion about journalism in America
and he made a strong plea for
journalists to abandon neutrality
he said it's it's that's over you've got
to come out and you've got to say
Trump's a racist Trump's a misogynist
Trump's a bigot so whatever you know
whatever your view is you've got to say
it you've got to sell it and that the
time for neutrality has passed and I do
believe he's persuaded and others have
come to their own conclusion that that's
the way forward that's why we had a
question there was another CNN debate
where Don Lemon specifically said how do
you answer voters who prioritize the
economy over Trump's bigotry right so
there's a judgement in there a judgement
yeah I'm just saying okay so if I met
many people may agree with that but it's
the anchors subjective judgement and it
doesn't belong in my view in a debate
question same ways the New York Times is
arguing the old schoolers with the young
folks about whether the time should be
quote part of the resistance but I guess
what the problem that I have with it is
not that someone shows an opinion I've
got a million opinions is that they're
lying about what it is and they're
saying we're journalists or objectives
why can't they drop the pretense and be
honest with us tell us
we're partisan combatants as they are we
already know I mean that's the real joke
right it's like we already know Fox News
was found at all you know 1996 right
they just had their birthday on the
premise that the other side of the
stories weren't being told and that half
the country was being ignored and that
if you did fair and balanced news the
people would watch and there was a
premise that the other media the
mainstream media maybe they weren't far
left right but that there was a baked-in
bias against people who believed in home
schooling who believed in a pro-life
position who might have a gun right and
so they made a whole empire based on
programming to those people I think
what's happened now on the other half of
the country on sort of the mainstream is
they've just they've gone they've
embraced it it was sort of passive and
now it's active
now it's let's work he's too bad we have
to work together right we'll be judged
history will judge us as whether we were
for or against this man okay so we were
planning to bring you a dot a Dennis
Robbin segment which we had a pre tape
earlier we're gonna say that for
tomorrow this is interesting if you
don't mind staying sure we'll be right
back we promised you a conversation with
Dennis Rodman on China in this segment
then we got too carried away talking to
megyn kelly so we're gonna continue that
and bring you a great interview so you
spent all these there's the news
business you should be taking a year off
you've been thinking assassin a probably
watching some news I hope a little a
little two days ago this report comes
out from Project Veritas on CNN and in
it whatever you think of their methods
they have the head of CNN Jeff Zucker
instructing his employees impeachment
impeachment impeachment we're hitting a
pitch where no matter what it doesn't
matter what you think impeachments the
only story that notice that sounded more
like a political campaign to me than a
news judgment well I mean patreon is a
big story for sure the president a
knighted state's gonna get impeached and
possibly bounced out of office it's a
major major story I would say so i'm i
think that's defensible on the part of
jeff zucker but I do think sort of the
the hyper focus on it by most of the
media too at the expense of all else is
not new right since the day Trump got
into office
they've been hyper focused on
impeachment and this is one of the
problems that the Democrats and also to
some extent the media is up against that
from the day he took office it was the
25th amendment the emoluments clause
Russia Russia Russia obstruction of
justice all of those things he has to be
impeached and if everything is in 11
nothing is in 11
now they may have actually stumbled upon
an 11 right they've got the transcript
for whatever Trump says it was perfect
call you can make an argument uh-huh but
no one's paying as much attention as the
otherwise would have if we hadn't been
told from the beginning that he needs to
be bounced out of office so you know I
don't know they can ratchet up the
coverage all they want I don't know
whether they're convincing anyone who
was on the fence or in the middle at all
I mean it seems like people are starting
to tune out in general from news
coverage because like how long can you
keep in our outraged culture right it's
like what am I supposed to be outraged
about again I'm gonna get there I'm
gonna get out right just give me two
seconds and I'm gonna and then you're
like Ukraine all right what about you
remember we talked about this at the
time at Trump's election there what you
know you've heard people say we need to
think about who his voters are there's a
whole world out there we in the media
know nothing about we should be
sympathetic to these Trump voters that
lasted for about 15 seconds know that
you're wrong they looked and they were
like oh there's a conscious decision we
don't want to go into that world No
right look at that with their guns in
their cowboy hats no right I just don't
think that the mainstream media has any
connection to flyover country and when
they when they meander through Montana
they're they've never seen such a thing
like it's a rodeo and they talk
differently shouldn't they different
values to understand the country they
cover look I think they think they do
right I think they believe they do but
you know I think most people for example
take a look at that the guy in
Washington State who wouldn't bake the
cake for the gay couple and they just
think bigoted bigoted media yeah and the
the problem is it's so much more
complicated than that
that's for sure right so speaking of I
have to ask you since you've you've had
this very well covered career yeah and
and you've taken a year to think what
have you learned after all of this
everything that's happened would you say
very little I don't learn so well yeah
I've learned like Woody Allen I'm 48
years old I've learned nothing no I have
learned a thing or two I mean I've what
comes to mind is the goodness of
humanity you know how the kindness of
strangers
just as awful as the media can be actual
humans are awesome and loving and kind
and helpful and really I think about it
[ __ ] because I left Fox News in
January of 17 and the reason I left is
because I wanted to be with my family
right I was missing my my kids childhood
they were little like seven five and
three so I I could still see it I could
still be a part of it and and how I'm
doing it you know I have spent the past
year in particular but even before that
with them and I'm mothering my own kids
and there's no substitute for that you
know I lost my dad when I was fifteen
years old and so I I know I know on an
inherent basis you don't get a do-over
right it's true so I'm I'm there and I'm
enjoying it and I get back on that horse
soon because this has been fun so I'll
probably get back out there but right
now I'm I'm still enjoying my my day to
day life my family and friends megyn
kelly thank you for the conversation you
for having sucker